welcome back to glamour unfiltered
posted by me Josh Smith your celebrity
interview franchise when we get to the
heart some issues that mean worse and
worse aspiring celebrities on this
entire planet and today we are joined by
the new queen of Netflix Zoe
Congrats
thank you you are slaying it in the
politician so evidently there's a
videotape with some footage of you using
an offensive gay slur do you have any
idea what I might be referring to do you
have any idea what combination that's
teen drama there's also very serious
issues in it race as well about suicide
gun control crime if you have this show
growing up how do you think it would
help to you as a young person there
isn't like this giant discussion about
how you identify sexually one of the
lead characters he likes men and women
but it's not it's never discussed that
he's bi or straight or yes gay you know
I
what a dream would be to live in a world
where it wasn't this your sexuality
wasn't a political stance you know that
it's such an interesting time that we
live in that you have to have this big
thing where you you declare who you are
to the world but what if you could just
be who you were and it wasn't again a
political statement to be who you are
and I love that about this show your
character is kind of an outsider in many
many ways how much of an outside of you
felt in your own life and how have you
grapple with that if you have done we
all always all feel like outsiders and
frauds and I think that's a very human
natural thing I wish I had advice to
give on that front do you feel like
you're on a journey of self-discovery
with yourself
certainly I'm about to be 25 and the
whole like quarter life crisis
existential dread thing is real it is
very hopeful thing that's so important
is to not actually for me I find it
important to not compare my insides to
other people's outsides it's so easy and
I mean that bite you look at something
and you go oh they have everything oh
they understand what they're doing oh
they have their together and they're
reality is really truly everybody is
struggling in one way or another that is
like the great common denominator
between every human being in the world I
just have never been I'm not somebody
who's like what does it all mean no not
necessary I wouldn't consider myself a
particularly philosophical creature
I guess it's it yeah I've definitely
random thoughts of just why are we all
here what does it all mean what's the
point so it's kind of like out of you
know I'm just driving in my car and I
thought like that'll pop in and I'll go
down without knowing I'm like going down
a really windy weird road and then
there's like a roadblock my mind is like
nope
you're not smart enough stop there you
can't go there okay well at least the
brain stopped me I was raised in the
community of I'm Jewish and in my in
that community it's like if you don't
see a therapist it's like what's wrong
with you and most parts of the world is
like you see it therapist what's wrong
with you you know it's the opposite you
know I'm I I am so I feel very very
lucky that that's so much a part of my
life is really talking through it and
and being open about what you're going
through I certainly have never been able
to come to any conclusion about myself
or my life without talking it out it
doesn't doesn't just I don't I'm unable
to arrive at any sort of helpful or
useful place without another human being
guiding me or listening to me or yeah so
you do you really need to talk to people
you need to just say hey will you listen
to I think listening is amazing as I
talk and talk and talk and you listen
never missing a skill as an interviewer
say on this thing we're here in vibes
yeah no it's it's not something a lot of
people are good at mmm what is your like
empowerment mantra when you're feeling
down I love something my mom told me
once which is so simple and I and and I
do believe very strongly that sometimes
the simplest things in life are really
the most profound
that that's saying you are enough I
think is really beautiful
I think it's all-encompassing I think if
people were to really apply that to
their own life and to their own
perception of themselves it would be a
lot less hard on ourselves and turn a
lot less hard on other people I mean
that's ultimately where judgment and
hate and anger and all that stuff comes
from is is like one of my favorite
things to say when someone's being
really hard on themselves like my sister
or one of my friends if they're like I
look absolutely terrible right now I
don't say that about my friend you know
just immediately like don't say that
about my friend don't talk about that
the person that I I love like that which
is such a funny way of not going down
the rabbit hole of like continuing to be
hard on yourself cuz then it's see
because then you're mad at yourself for
being hard on yourself just I think
keeping it simple and not being so hard
on yourself is is really not I think we
should take advantage of that more often
obviously this is sat in the high school
what was high school life you went to a
really cool arts high school that was
really special and neat to be around a
bunch of other like-minded people with
teenagers with purposive behaviors how I
always say it because it feels like the
easiest way to just summarize that
everybody had a purpose yeah
rather than popularity as everybody had
something that they wanted to do
everyone in some level in this show is
using a platform for good or for bad how
stressed out do you feel about having a
platform and how much responsibility do
you feel for it
I think right now I feel more than
anything of gratitude for it I'm
recognizing it more than ever the
privilege it is to one be allowed to
have a voice and two to have a platform
to use that voice so many people in this
world are not able to talk about the way
that they feel about their political
climate and they don't have a place to
do it even if they wanted to so if
anything I feel it's a privilege and I
said quote with great power comes great
responsibility yeah like I think they're
a do feel a responsibility
I do feel I do relate to the idea that
when you have the privilege to speak up
that silence does not make you safe I
understand the narrative that some
people have which is factors are not
politicians they're actors but also
we're human beings human beings have
feelings and opinions and i-i-i think
it's it's a privilege and an honor what
do you think somebody's pressing is she
for you sitting today in today's society
I think the thing that immediately I
mean the thing that I've always been
really passionate about the thing that I
always come back to is women's health
and reproductive rights which shouldn't
be under the umbrella of politics as far
as I'm concerned or be a discussion of
like women being in the minority 51% of
the population lots of stuff on that
front
why are tampons taxed does that make
sense why is our politicians able to
discuss when and if and how we have
children it doesn't make sense those
kind of things really pissed me off how
much does that IV it really angers me
but I find that to be a motivating
emotion rather than a destructive
emotion do you sing here today feel more
empowered than ever before and what's
your journey with empowerment biddin I I
don't I don't know I'm not sure I don't
know anything I don't I don't know
anything at all oh god am i what is it
all mean I do weirdly feel optimistic
yeah I don't know I cannot pinpoint why
I feel oddly optimistic I feel oddly
excited about the future I feel like
things have to get better so there's
that yeah and I feel very empowered in
the
in the in the in my community of like
actresses I feel very excited about this
I feel like it's more unifying and more
together than ever before and that's
really cool look how much phase we like
the sweat please normal but I guess no
more but non-stop this is what we use
your platform to talk about sweat oh my
god my first job I had I was on the
Disney Channel and everybody wears those
like crazy skin tight like bright happy
colors and I it was like a live audience
up and in between every single scene in
front of the live audience that they
would bring in five hairdressers with
blow dryers and dry my armpits and I'd
be in front of like a live audience like
a 15 year old blow-drying my armpits in
front and then they finally started
putting pads like okay really pads in my
shirts and it still didn't work and I
was like this is actual this is
humiliation never I've never ever heard
of anything more humiliating than that
so here I am baring my soul slash sweaty
armpits for the world more empowering
videos now Abby see you in two weeks
so of glamour and builted and there will
be some sweat filters on that one yeah
yeah yeah yeah keeping it real little
bit ruin it real thanks guys
[Music]